and my wife started sending an email out
to all of our family here's what we're
doing this this holiday season we'd love
for you to be a part of it it might only
be 24 hours this year it might be a week
next year whatever that looks like um
but here's what we're doing and then the
adults in our lives get to choose are
they going to be upset they're going to
be happy they're going to be overjoyed
they're going to join us they're going
to not join us that's that's the choices
they're
making or my dad calls and says hey we
would really mean a lot to us if you did
this awesome we're going to try to
figure that out
but it's grownup time talking to
grown-up time